they say in anime siblings make some of
the most important characters well in
addition to providing foils to our main
characters they also make some of the
best rivals that have their own parallel
stories going on and fight they often do
some of the most impactful fights in the
mediums history are between siblings
those who whose faith seamlessly weave
over each other leading to the moment of
that decisive clash so in today's video
I'll talk about 10 of the most impactful
sibling battles in anime these are some
of the best fights in their series and
they either complete or set the stage
for a lot more crucial plot developments
before anything I'll be leaving a
spoiler warning for some of the fights
on this list I think it's just right for
an action-packed series like a gamma guy
killed to have an impactful sibling
fights well a lot of them at least
actually egami and Kuro may just make
the perfect foils for each other whether
it be their appearances or the abilities
of their swords wielding their swords
both which are tied to the concept of
life the two take to battle in one of
the most important scenes in the akame
ga kill anime despite enhancing herself
with drugs who row mate still finds her
decisive battle with her sister a close
one agama is more assam a would come out
victorious after an intense struggle as
I said before the fight has a different
ending in the manga so it might be worth
checking out if you want to see a
different perspective or a different
sequence of events
ninth place is Inuyasha versus
Sesshomaru you know the recent news
about the return of Inuyasha got me
going on a trip down memory lane when I
was young I always liked the story
between Inuyasha and Sesshomaru broken
down the feud between the two of them is
basically all just about to sword
however things go much deeper than that
and they're multiple on-screen fights
are merely pieces leading to the final
phase of their character arcs in the
series I think that the most important
one among those battles is the one where
Sesshomaru receives help from Naraku you
know the main villain of the series and
his thirst for power he even goes as far
as to accept help from the big bad in
order to achieve his one desire it was a
momentous occasion in the anime but I
think it's more important for leading to
Sesshomaru z' character development I
mean eventually he lets go of his desire
for the tessaiga and ends up with a
sword that I think is even more powerful
all's well that ends well right next we
have Natsu versus zareff at number eight
okay I think this one's a bit more
spoiler ish but fairy tales being done
for quite some time now so I just assume
a lot of people already know by now that
zeref and Natsu are actually brothers
with that dynamic in mind having the two
of them battle it out in part one of the
double head of final boss fights in
Fairy Tail is all the more poetic they
already have had a previous battle in
the final arc but that's nothing
compared to the final decisive one when
they're pretty much both at peak form if
each is Natsu releasing his built-up
powers and forms along with an
appearance by fairy hearts arif mavis
also gets involved as expected the two
collide in a final clash with Natsu
emerging victorious having finally found
his match zeref peacefully departs and
leaves the fate of the world to the
wizards to decide after all the battles
not done and they still have ACMA logia
to deal with goku vs Raddatz finds
itself as the number seven fighter on
the list times when Dragon Ball was a
bit simpler - what we ended up with over
the course of its run the key part of
early Dragonball is the Raddatz arc
featuring Goku's brother who's every bit
different from what he is and I say that
in a negative light because Raddatz is
one of the harsh and more brutal
characters in early Dragonball the two
would square off in the climax of the
arc but we eventually see that raddest
didn't come alone
he had reinforcements in the form of
piccolo that would prove instrumental to
his death and it was piccolo special
beam cannon that would do him in for
good and he was having such a good run
against Goku - wasn't it this fight is
impactful because when you look at it it
would eventually lead to the arrival of
nappa and Vegeta we all know how
important these two characters end up
being and without this fight and how it
ended we probably wouldn't have gotten
go whose top rival into the story
as early as the start of kill la kill I
knew that this moment would be one of
the defining battles in the entire
series that's why I was surprised to see
the big fight between ryuko and Satsuki
take place
midway through the show's run turns out
it was merely a setup for the eventual
final villain the fight itself is one of
the best moments in the show as triggers
knack for simply being awesome in doing
high-octane over-the-top fights truly
shines in their delivery overall this
fight is just great and it gave us the
cool moment of ryuko powering up with
Gamu recent get sue gave me chills that
one did kill la kill has a lot of great
in chilling moments of Awesome and this
is right up there along with the finale
featuring Marco reviving the engines in
order to help ryuko hmm both of these
moments also have the same insert song
in the background looks like I'm seeing
a little pattern here for a number 5
fight we have Vash versus knives good
I'll try again how I've missed you in
addition to being a tense fight being
siblings I think that this fight shines
because it's ultimately a fight between
ideals this has a lot to do with knives
backstory which gets explored even
further
it starts out with knives having the
upper hand due to his knowledge of angel
arm however Vash does turn the tides on
him and he was defeated before being
taken back to the village the fight
itself isn't bad and I liked how it was
handled we might have become used to the
fireworks of modern anime but I think
this fights aged pretty well we don't
see a lot of amazing art and as it's
colloquially called Sarkoja but I think
that in terms of weight and the
importance of conflict this is one of
the top fights in that era of anime the
anime makes knives fate unknown but he
does survive the battle in the manga
given its long run it's no surprise that
Gintama has some of the best fights in
anime this includes of course a key
sibling fight between Kagura and karma
we that takes place in the Shogun
assassination art after spending so long
looking down on his sister karma we
finally gets to acknowledge his siblings
abilities after getting a taste of Gangu
as metal the two fight on and while
Kamui claims the Kagura is still not
strong enough the sister rebuffs that by
showing her determination to protect her
home from anything including from her
far stronger brother
the fight then gets interrupted with the
interference of Naraku the two siblings
who were out for blood to suddenly find
themselves fighting alongside each other
in a nice little twist I think that
that's a good way to keep the feud going
while not giving out the decisive winner
just yet
akamaru's journey has been a long one
and when he meets his brother for the
final confrontation the completion of
his quest is at hand I find it so
fitting to have our protagonists own
sibling be the last obstacle in his
mission to become whole again it helps
that the Burning Castle serves as an
epic setting to the final fight in the
series the two engaged in a long fight
that sends them all around the castle in
their struggle as expected he akamaru
comes out on top but being the nice guy
that he is he spares his brother of
course we can't just have an ending like
that can we so a demon has to come out
and make the home aru sacrifice himself
before wrapping yukimaru's quest to
become whole in a touching moment well
that's the most epic house tour if I've
ever seen one truly one of the best
fights in 2019 while we're at it why not
check that video out too
there are many things to like about fire
force stepping up as one of the newest
hits in the world of shown in anime fire
force has found its way to the watchlist
of many fans a lot of that has to do
with the creative powers the fanservice
and most importantly the cool fights one
such cool fight that I think served
really well as the climax of the first
part is the battle between Shinhwa and
Shou
I also penciled in this fight as one of
the best in 2019 and I still stand by
that statement this battle is intense
gives us a matchup that we all want you
to see and I'd say that the animation
for this battle ended up being just
awesome if you're talking about top
moments in fire force period I'd give
this intense sibling fight a serious
consideration for the absolute top spot
it's a fight that I think surpasses what
we got in the manga and I think this
fight deserves much more recognition in
the community
[Music]
ultimately a great sibling fight in a
shounen anime completes multiple
character arcs in a spectacular show of
amazing powers and gripping feelings
that's exactly what it are t vs sasuke
is for so long as Sasuke's being driven
by his desire for revenge against his
brother and after years and years in
real life of teasing the fight we
finally got the confrontation and boy it
didn't disappoint the fight shows the
two og has got all-out showing off
powers we've never seen before in there
blaze of glory before this fight we've
mostly seen the story from Sasuke's
perspective and how he acquired power
after power in his bid to finally
overcome his brother yet the battle
still proved to be quite even for the
most part ultimately Sasuke would emerge
victorious however his victory wouldn't
be met with a lot of celebration he
finally completed his goal but I'd argue
that it was quite the empty victory
given his brother's revelations
afterwards it was a truth that
overturned Sasuke's understanding of the
world and it helped me to pick this
fight as the most impactful sibling
battle in anime so what do you think of
this list do you agree or disagree with
some of the choices that I put in it let
me know in the comments section below
what you think of this list and what
fights you believe should have been
included for now that's got to be it I
look forward to seeing you in another
video soon we still have a lot of anime
to talk about
[Music]